Bonjour à toutes et à tous!
Aujourd'hui
je vais faire appel à votre imagination
et à votre amour pour les films
catastrophe...
Vous avez tous en tête les images de Deep impact, Armageddon, où d'énormes corps célestes
se collisionnent entre eux dans une phase apocalyptique de formation planétaire ?
Et voilà ma question:  A quoi ressemble la
planète après une telle collision ?
Au cours de sa formation il a plus de 4
milliards d'années la terre
n'a pas eu la vie facile.
Elle a subi de nombreuses collisions
avec des corps célestes dont certains
pouvaient avoir la taille de Mars.
D'ailleurs notre lune est probablement
le résultat d'un tel impact.
Après chaque collision le mélange des corps célestes
à une planète influence son évolution
sur le long terme.
Sa composition, sa température, son orbite,
est ce qu'elle va avoir un champ
magnétique, un champ de lavande ?
Bref tout cela aura donc des
conséquences sur son habitabilité
et son potentiel touristique.
Des chercheurs de l'Institut de
recherche sur les phénomènes hors équilibre de Marseille
ont décidé
d'étudier expérimentalement ce qu'il se
passe lorsqu'un planètèsimal - un bébé
planète -
rencontre une protoplanète
une planète dans sa phase d'adolescence en quelque sorte.
Ho vas-y tu me saoules,
retourne dans son orbite..
Il faut imaginer que ces deux corps célestes
sont déjà différenciés, c'est à dire
qu'ils ont un noyau riche en fer au centre,
et en surface de la roche plus ou
moins solide qui va se liquéfier au
moment où l'impact.
Au moment de l'impact, le planétésimal est pulvérisé
Le fer de son noyau qui est alors chaud
et sous forme liquide se retrouve mêlé
à l'océan de magma qu'il va traverser,
entraîné par la gravité.
La température et la composition finale de la planète vont donc dépendre de l'efficacité
des échanges entre le magma et le fer
pendant cette phase.
Et c'est justement cette phase de
mélange fer-magma que les chercheurs
ont choisi d'étudier expérimentalement.
Normal. Quoi de plus simple que de
recréer un impact et un océan de magma
en laboratoire ?
Oui ben ramenez moi un peu plus
d'océan de magma là.
Voilà, maintenant on
fait la même chose avec celui de 600
milliards de milliards de tonnes.
Allez, c'est parti !
Non, en réalité les scientifiques
se sont munis d'une cuve de plus d'un
mètre de haut, remplie d'un mélange d'eau
et d'un produit pour la rendre plus
visqueuse.
Pour modéliser le noyau de fer liquide
qui arrive au moment de l'impact
ils utilisent du Galinstan.
Je vous arrête tout de suite, le galinstan
n'est pas un pays d'Asie centrale,
c'est un alliage contenant
principalement du gallium
et qui a l'avantage d'être liquide à pression et
température ambiante.
Enfin pour recréer l'impact ils placent le
galinstan légèrement chauffé dans
un ballon en haut de la cuve...
et ils l'éclatent.
Les chercheurs étudient
alors le comportement de la goutte
initiale du blob de galinstan
au cours de sa descente.
Filmé à 800 images seconde avec une
caméra ultrarapide ça donne ça :
Vous voyez ici l'analogue d'un noyau de fer liquide
qui plonge dans un océan de
magma peu visqueux.
Jusque récemment cette
phase était uniquement décrite par des
modèles théoriques.
Certains imaginent un blob qui descend
quasiment sans se fractionner alors que
d'autres prévoient que le fer traverse
l'océan de magma sous forme de pluie.
Mais ce qu'ont montré les chercheurs par
cette expérience, c'est que le
comportement du blob va notamment
dépendre de la différence de viscosité
entre le fer et le magma.
Voici trois
expériences filmé à 1000 images/seconde.
On part exactement du même ballon de galinstan
qui représente le fer,
et seule change la viscosité du liquide environnant.
De gauche à droite :
même viscosité que le galinstan,
cent soixante dix fois plus visqueux et
1600 fois plus visqueux.
Donc plus l'océan de magma est visqueux, moins le blob se fragmente durant sa descente.
Or plus le blob se divise en
gouttelettes, plus le mélange sera
efficace et meilleures seront les
échanges de chaleur et d'éléments
entre le fer et le magma.
Et les chercheurs ont remarqué que la
distance à partir de laquelle le blog se
divise en gouttelettes dépend de sa
taille initiale.
Le blob  se divise après
avoir parcouru une distance d'environ 13
fois son diamètre en début de chute.
Ainsi cette recherche a permis de tester
la validité de différentes théories sur
la formation des planètes grâce à une
approche expérimentale.
Et puis surtout
ça fait de magnifiques images !
Voilà. Donc cette fois pour trouver la
chute c'était plutôt fluide
je viens de la trouver ...galinstan.
N'hésitez pas à aimer partager commenter
et abonnez vous
pour ne pas en perdre une goutte !